i
is this
before
since the lack of nothing
is already
meat
on this land
in querétaro it
has been learning
from the stand of waivers
camagüey crowe
jaguars ashfaq in [ __ ]
the after hansel when they hang out with
stores where author hands sings understands
that walking
attraction fish
here
at the same time
and nothing
and it's true
this
king machine to
make a profit they are not so good where they
understand andante
there are times it's hard
to take
every day
zac zac
in zurich
d
and the baby
and
the people know it
true nascar with new offices of  fort we
have to finish
the factor it's not
this disease
r
i sometimes
and that it was regal
so it's my turn to
continue water pac
[Applause]
ruiz's fault it
's easy to know why you give me
t I mean it's not it
's that there is
the escalator
so that watson jr
what
this class
[Applause]
javier setting agreement that this serious
crisis is
nothing
true
and is
going
on like that,
cool tarazona
ah
shave
the eighth
place
the labels will be until January
i  leave me wanting on
top
[Music]
and here
my part
and constant are
not lacking
[Music]
the city
this its string crippen me
if you wanted
for those people
so that
cancer falls
you will get to be
the sky sense
oh
I'll stay
to  times
shaving why else
ah
then to hit that has white
hectare
matters edition
this month to do
ah
[ __ ] well
that
every time you are going to do
fa
if you have the starz pac channel
no no no
2 she
is an actress and she
has come to me here she knows
ok
That's why the king did
n't tell me well
about passes
today 7 six-year term
of AFAC
the truth
ah
the face
guasave why
the capital
apart
we will do
so that you mark
health
so that you have me
yeah
so that of her
more
to love already
that is
ah let's
see what
coli and chachachá
chavez we
have to put water
in fiction
[Music] let's
help flowers to madoff and 'the sun'
for kinect
charge of make my work for
what's going on
today it will be that I am once
true
pastrana the love that I  mu  rde
[Music]
[Applause]
on 6-6 my fortune
in Soria would
stand out
if you have it
[Music]
if you see
[Applause]
breaking
dad
to see
[Music]
but that
in the state of barinas
her
but for them already  ex-model
kill
truth
app
baby
affect our luck
people through these small
on the plane
look travelers
reedy taking against the rays
habitat sabe
[Applause]
they fall
why
and me
and it's perfect
as
thanks
in the saved and water the sandwiches
is  this
after writing I'm a mom
haha
we were tenerife at sea in that nation
long after neuer
it will look
very good to
water the pp
[Music]
in the long shadow gas slide
the hardware
and
already close to here is my master's degree
but
I'm going to fight  to create shoot
the bees take out uadec
to want wefaq of the 3rd
I leave you that nobody except
here were
to give
or
today serious
[Applause]
fifa water
treat
the trees already
ah
[Applause]
was b  Well it
's expensive
why why
green
medals
[Applause]
what are
those
[Applause]
to
create part
m
is denied
in this
cappa
what is it for it is
not enough
[ __ ] you will see
the report
peace
to this diet
yes
e
you have to raise your voice
he wins
[Applause]
flavor sound sorgin
save line was shown
it should be noted that he is going to more
than
to be captain
to bulgaria
for kms
there is a return to blatter there is san fermin
peace we
must talk about
this sect champions
now
there are others that are on paper
here it is  the talk
wow
yes
it makes me sad to see there we were when
adding
[ __ ]
until you
but we will try
and
ah
but not
to bassedas
and now
the idea
not
the layers
etc
i
do not want
to take
when I said look at the d
ave
that order money
[Music  ]
the sentence
[Applause]
the professions of the internet
and Asia
did not play
[Music]
here
the granddaughter of Mrs. Dalia